reached out to this man i i respect his
work immensely he is terrific at what he
does and the best part about what he
does i'll be honest with he can write
he can write very well he puts things in
plain language and also can describe
things that are very difficult to
understand into language you can
understand and nothing could be more
important when covering a lockout which
he now unfortunately does from the
worldwide leader in sports senior rider
uh covering baseball jeff passing how
are you doing jeff
you cashed that check yes or no uh i
have yet to cash the check of 5.59 that
i got from my two episodes of csi miami
work yes i have not done that will will
you however cash uh the words damn and
straight uh i think when string together
describe exactly what i will do with
that check absolutely i will cash that
check oh yeah it's 5.59 cents it all
adds up sir it all adds up i was going
to say where where is it what's it going
to go toward what are you going to do
i don't know i might uh i might get a
burger i don't know i might uh i might
yeah i might i might i don't know a
little turkey burger because you know
i'm trying to watch it you know it's
that time of year i don't know but um
i'm trying to get are you trying to get
your 40 time down
yeah you know it's never too early to
pro to to get ready for how about this
i'm hoping that by the time i run the 40
at the combine in the first week of
march that this conversation we're about
to have we'll all be uh buttoned up what
do you think what do you think
i
am cautiously optimistic
by that point major league baseball and
the players association will have a deal
because frankly if they don't at that
point we're missing games
and if if regular seating games are
missed that is a big problem for
everybody involved it it runs the risk
at that point of spiraling into
something that it shouldn't which is why
i'm heartened by
the fact that we have a few months left
for the parties to try and reach an
agreement because frankly
there's no single issue
at this point that is keeping them so
far apart that they can't find a pathway
to a deal there is pathway to a deal
they just you know i i think
now that we're in the lockout phase uh
is when the real negotiations and
bargaining are going to start well now
that's now that's part of the reason why
i wanted to have you on that these are
two things i wanted to get from you and
we kind of already um are in the
neighborhood of of one of them the two
things i want to get from you are the
issues that truly are
the ones that are going to be the most
difficult to hammer out because there's
probably some fire and brimstone owners
and some fire and brimstone players that
say screw it let's burn it down to the
ground and build it back up again
because that's the only opportunity we
have to do it right now we haven't had
this opportunity since 1990 and screw it
and that's the way you know uh you you
do miss games that's number one is i
want to know what those issues are and
then that's well number two and number
one is the drop dead date like what is
the midnight the stroka midnight date
that exists in people's minds that they
can screw around and say the most nasty
things and eventually put humpty dumpty
back together in time for because i
remember that's the way it worked for
the nfl what do you have for me on that
front and that's how it's working here
too um the the big thing is there's no
singular issue like major league
baseball wants a salary cap on the table
right now this is very simply rich a
fight about money and a fight about the
division of this you know during a
normal non-coveted year 10 billion
dollar pie
and players
understandably feel like they've gotten
the short end of the stick revenues in
baseball have grown pretty significantly
and
salaries have not
and and when you see uh you know a graph
that shows this line going upward for
clubs
and aligned that steady and even this
past year went down for players you know
you're going to have contention there so
while the players say you know we want
competitive integrity yeah you don't
want teams tanking because tanking teams
mean
teams that don't spend and teams that
don't spend means fewer in free agency
and fewer options than free agency means
lower salaries for players it's a very
simple fact
players want to get paid
more earlier in their careers
understandable baseball's reserve system
has it such that for the first three
years of your career you get paid right
around the major league minimum which
don't get me wrong it's great right now
it's five hundred seventy thousand five
hundred dollars it is going to go up and
could go up fairly significantly but uh
it's beyond that if you have a great
player in his zero to three uh service
class
uh you know they want bonuses for the
ones who are excellent who are all stars
who get mvp votes etc and again a
totally understandable thing
the problem is the players want a lot
more than that too uh right now it takes
six years for them to reach free agency
they
you know they would like it to be
shorter or especially for players who
don't get called up until later in their
careers uh maybe some sort of an age
based system though that probably
ultimately is going to be off the table
they want arbitration uh which is where
you can negotiate your salary right now
in your fourth through uh six seasons
they want that after two years instead
of having oh boy now that's that's where
the owners will be like you got to be
kidding me because i know they hate
arbitration and you know and also
well and players and players may like it
but they also it's it's a team that
comes in and tells an arbitrator our guy
stinks you know
yeah
he's great here but here's where he also
stinks and and and and that whole
process does stink jeff i mean so so so
you're mentioning a lot of things that
are on the table but what's the one
thing that's going to actually
you know be the last thing on the table
that that that that everyone's going to
threaten games aren't going to be played
and and and you know the commissioner's
going to come out and say players aren't
aren't doing what they're supposed to be
doing at this table they're the ones who
are walking away like that's the way
it's going to go when it when is that
date when when is that date where they
finally decide that we we we need to get
this done because if we don't get spring
training on time that means april
doesn't happen on time when does that
happen i'm going to throw i'm going to
throw a couple dates out to you i think
february 1st is an important date i
think if there is no movement
by february 1st then suddenly things
start getting a little tricky things
start getting a little perilous
but but ultimately rich this is about
missing regular season games missing
spring training games would be bad
because spring training has become a big
revenue driver for major league clubs so
they don't want to do that but march 1st
is the day that i have targeted in my
mind if there's not an agreement in
place by march 1st
it's going to be pretty perilous now we
saw during covet that players can get
ready for a season in about three weeks
they did that during the covert year
they can do it here but let's remember
all of the different things that have to
go on in addition to getting the season
ready um
there's still a bunch of really good
free agents who are out there right now
despite the fact that you know a billion
seven was spent in november to sign guys
and and we're on our way to absolute
record revenues in free agency for
players uh carlos correa is still out
there freddie freeman's out there trevor
story's still out there like not just
like
marginal guys like there are dudes still
out there and on top of that you know
there are hundreds of players who don't
have jobs at this point so you're going
to have a crazy frenzy when the lockout
ends trying to just simply construct
teams on top of that there's the issue
with latin american players of getting
visas if a player is not in the country
right now then it's going to be a
difficult thing to get him a visa uh and
have him in there on time if you're not
you know in agreement by march 1st so
that's the day in my mind that that i'm
really targeting is important i i think
yep and granted i'm being optimistic
here i think there will be a deal in
place before then because despite the
fact that we are in the ninth work
stoppage in major league baseball
history rich i still think that there is
a pathway to a deal and now that we're
in the lockout phase
to me it's going to be a lot easier for
them to figure it out because
frankly they see the writing on the wall
they understand that if they don't get
moving on this soon that it has a chance
to imperil the entire sport no i know
that that's a reasonable approach jeff
but like i told you i just remember when
when when this happened with the nfl
there are going to be some owners and
some who have a lot of influence
who are saying we haven't had this
opportunity in a long time and don't
don't worry about the fans we'll take
care of that you know and and we'll
pound the table and we'll tarn feather
the players and you know they're the
ones who have got you know uh more to
lose they don't want to lose paychecks
let's do what we've always wanted to do
and then there'll be some players
that'll say the same thing
and that is what leads to the ultimate
peril is what i'm saying you know and so
what let's go on the flip side i just
remember for the nfl lockout you know um
and and i've also heard that this might
have been a little bit overplayed uh as
in terms of a narrative but jeff
saturday of the colts and bob kraft of
the patriots got together remember they
famously hugged it out um you know in
front of cameras
is is there a relationship that we
should be keeping an eye on like that in
baseball as we go forward on this thing
jeff yeah not not at this point no one
no one's hugging right now
we are that's it far from the hugging
phase at this point or just an owner
that can reach out to a player in in the
association or something like that is
there a back channel that you might know
of or anything about that yeah i i mean
those sorts of things emerge over time
there's always back channeling going on
and there are always
even third parties who are trying to
go and bridge the gap but at this point
no they're they both sides are very
locked in on their positions and
until there is a move and listen there
there were there were small moves this
week right uh the
the league proposed getting rid of uh
what's called direct draft pick
compensation so when you have a star
player who's about to be a free agent
you can give him a qualifying offer
which this year was a one year 18.4
million dollar contract if a player
rejects that goes to free agency and
signed somewhere else
the team that signed him has to give up
a draft pick and because of that
teams are less likely to either pursue
particular players or to pay them what
their fair and free market value would
be
and because of that major league
baseball recognizes this is an
impediment
on free agency and offered to take
direct draft pick compensation off the
table that that was actually a pretty
significant move
uh on the other hand the the union which
had opposed expanding playoffs uh
proposed a 12 game excuse me a 12 team
playoff expanded from the 10 right now
but not quite to the 14 that major
league baseball won
as well as the ability to put patches on
uniforms which of course would be
sponsorship dollars in the pockets of
the teams every year so 14 teams jeff
come on man
this week but in terms of the the core
economics um there was not a whole lot
and they're still fighting over those
and when they do get back to the
bargaining table we're i think we're
really going to get a better sense of
what that big issue is going to be and
how it's going to be resolved well i'll
tell you this and jeff pass in a couple
more minutes left with the mlb insider
and uh senior writer at espn covering
the sport um i i was um surprised and i
guess a little bit heartened to see all
these deals that did get made beforehand
you know because that means that
everyone
knows that business is going to be
somewhat remotely close to usual like
that the rules won't be so far afield
that players aren't thinking i'm going
to hold off right now and see if uh if
the rules change to the point where i
might get less they're clearly thinking
they're going to get just the same
amount if not like that that whatever
scherzer took is going to be market
value after this clearly scott boris
isn't going to let anybody do that right
so
so um
putting it all together i i mean the
wander franco contractor i'll put it all
together to you for you um
the fact that as much money was spent
tells me that
uh both players and owners believe that
there's going to be a 2022 season a
pretty substantive 2022 season the the
reason it came together in free agency
as quickly as it did rich is because
there's a deadline
and for a long time people throughout
the sport have advocated for some kind
of a deadline because
we have to understand the difference
between baseball free agency and the
other sports
in the nfl in the mba in the nhl you
have a salary cap system teams know
exactly how much money they have to
spend players
value is pretty static so you know what
it's going to cost to go out and get a
guy
and because of that you can have this
frenzy of contract signings at the
beginning of a free agent period it's
why we see adam schefter and adrian
morginowski uh you know dropping bombs
all day long the first 72 hours of free
agency and then the rest of the free
agent period seems just kind of dead
baseball's never operated that way
baseball's always been uh such that you
know the the contracts can be
outlandish and and we saw one of those
with corey seeger this week getting 325
million dollars over 10 years from the
texas rangers so uh to have baseball
with an artificial thing in place
like this uh lockout deadline
in which no free agent contracts can be
signed no players can be traded you look
at mlb.com and mlb network now and and
they don't even reference players uh or
have their names image or likenesses up
there i mean it's pretty crazy to see
and what it fueled was an unprecedented
free agent market well um jeff passin
you have uh many a december and january
standups uh outside of uh fronts of
hotels coming your way um
you've got uh
yeah you also i i wound up through the
nfl lockout uh getting an honorary law
degree from the tulane sports law
program gabe feldman gave that to me
because i became such an expert on these
subject matters uh that's your next two
months hopefully not longer
so hey thank you i appreciate the
optimism super psyche no get a good get
a good pair of shoes i mean albert breer
literally could have lived outside on
the corner on washington dc outside the
nfl pa's front offices um i did so many
of those with him um
so get comfortable shoes and uh and
learn your law degree and then uh then
we'll talk later on how does that sound
yeah you're gonna have to call me jeff
passing jd from now on okay there you go
there you go counselor thank you i give
you a hug through the uh through the
phone thanks again appreciate it
see you buddy you got it chef passing
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here